[Music]
in new tax news oh right submitted by I
need to go to sip with two exclamation
point yeah yeah you better go you gotta
just enacted a five cent daily tax to
access social media we need money out
there though right I would get so much
done if I had to pay access social media
holy [ __ ] so you're not using you want X
it maybe help me yeah I can imagine how
much more we would be more connected to
each other versus being on our phones
all the time and you see those group of
kids that are just hanging out
everyone's on their phone but then if
you have to pay five bucks by five cents
five cents five cents might be five
bucks so I don't know that how they it
cannot big economical economy works out
there but the economical thing is
convergence although I feel like it
would be like most things that are
supposed to control behavior through
pricing or taxing like smokers it's like
just pay if y'all gonna shake it you're
nothing I mean we pay for all these
subscriptions I feel like people are
gonna pay for social media you better
make your DMS worth it you know sliding
into them may be better dang how does it
work so every time you open up your
phone or some [ __ ] or how does it do you
know like apparently they're saying that
they'll just be an upfront daily fee all
just everything social media sites damn
how is that different from the plans
that we have now is it five cents a day
daily fights yet oh that's cool I
thought say your five cents a minute I
don't think is if I is if I sent an app
an app right cuz it's like if you go to
Instagram it's like now you gotta pay
five cents in Twitter please call it a
daily levy they should just limit how
many likes you can do per day really
then people wouldn't be such like [ __ ]
yeah everybody exactly what you like you
know I mean like thanks less there's so
many like [ __ ] out there just [ __ ]
constantly I think I'm one of those oh
you definitely are we all talk about it
some people
some people like their own [ __ ] no
that's weird I was on my friends phone
and I'm like silent my calling it are
you liking your own photos that happened
I accidentally liked mine a couple times
oh well you know what I have it was like
you know sometimes like on Instagram you
know how you could see what everybody
likes yeah I I would like like the like
a bunch of girl pictures and then like
people will call me out of home needs to
be like bro you like like 40 titty
pictures and so now I just like throw
off the trail by liking some art some
art [ __ ] art dicks like I'm going off
the scent you know I mean off the scent
like oh yeah art art wait back it up
though why are your homies even looking
at what other people there homies
meeting girls I got in trouble with
girls at home home girls home alright
no but you also don't want to look like
you know a dude who's just like looking
at girls only on Instagram there's
plenty pictures what else is there to do
I know that's the only reason I don't
need is just cars girls gun food dog
puppy and karate that's fine but you
know I only had one thing and I had just
titties up I had to mix it up damn
that's pretty excessive do you actually
follow counselors for titties no no no
no every year I do a cleanse of people I
follow
oh I delete default follow I'm trying to
feed his [ __ ] babies he probably
doesn't even know I have a baby
Wow no I know you guys the other baby I
follow Bart
I learned how to do proper leg lifts to
Bart and how to raise a child through
Bart I have noticed that the more people
that I know who are parents like after
having kids usually they kind of start
letting themselves go and so they stop
posting their own faces and post more
baby pics and more babies until they
don't even post themselves anymore just
kid pix are you talking about one of my
friends talk about you know I'm talking
about I'm talking about a bunch of
people on Facebook if you got a couple
with a kid well sure but then also like
but you lose your identity sometimes the
moms make a comeback and then they're
all hot and then they show like a before
and after picture there's my pregnancy
and now this is me and announced all
about them and then their kids are like
on once they got the comeback right
there then you get the comments like
girl you are great I can't believe it
you're a mother
if you got a cut if you got a couple
with like one kid do you really have to
follow both of the members in that you
know like yes you got to follow one you
know everything that's going on and the
more important
yes you do okay our kid has 185 has a
brand deal with pampers on my discovery
right like most of it is Tyga's face or
barbell or fitness [ __ ] don't even fit
in it I don't even follow like fitness
pages it's because of these guys I'll
tell you people love to follow like
positive vibe stuff or like like
positive vibe stuff I realized I've been
negative like for years can I post it
like a positive thing about like a life
change like I'm taking a hike and I got
the most likes like oh [ __ ] maybe I
should do that dude what was it like
come on hike I'm reflecting about things
and it was a I did it the partnership
with like uh some anti smoking I don't
smoke you know saying so like I it was
easy for me to do that but I didn't
realize how many people would like that
picture and I was like mad that that was
my most liked than it was an act like I
was like mad about that shows how much I
must come back like your friends think
you are I know
doing a positive thing don't go not all
the homies were just [ __ ] on me
they're like get the [ __ ] a D that's
what I thought I was like this was
hiking with the beanie fire all like
you're roasty stuff I'm not I don't do
that on Rosa
you don't battle a rap and roast you
anymore nah I used to [ __ ] charcoal
burn people mad no man I'm just stopping
that's too nice name use in now oh damn
I'm an artist I always liked it please
yeah so why are they putting this text
on the ugandan ins they don't want
people jacking off all day on internet
why they're dope you know yeah they're a
long time leader has complained about
online gossip oh my god you know these
people these people always talking
behind my back Internet's do that this
is like the least of the worries that
you might have in Uganda yeah he's the
President of Uganda his name is Yuri
Musa Vinny they got food over there I
don't know if it's like what are those a
[Music]
part of me was like now's ignorant his
book other side was like serious I was
thinking I was like well I don't like
Congo got problems right now I've had
homies who Ghana Uganda like but my
hobby went to like to do like a Miss
mission kind of situation oh yeah but I
don't I'm pretty sure they have like
thriving areas too but see that's
parties no Uganda though I've never
heard somebody say I went to Uganda to
vacation it's always like I went to
Uganda to help yeah yeah like that's
kind of the whole thing
oh you know what area and Africa made a
comeback that place where they did the
[ __ ] is it Black Hawk Down hmm I'd
say you're about to say what Conda and I
was like that's not a rule that's not no
was it black by brain iam they don't
think what computer
well cotton is thriving on the other
hand that place is killing it
oh no it's where they had the genocide
forget it Joe anyway yeah yeah we're so
smart we don't know [ __ ] about Africa
the social media attacks have angered
very
very many people because they're saying
that it's an attack on free speech Oh
what wait who's free I mean they're free
roaming right free
yeah China already said [ __ ] all that
way early on they were like cutting off
Google's so you know they got it easy
for at least five cents for that you
know true yeah but they're just saying
that but yeah it's funny because the
president was mad about gossip so that's
the reason why yeah he ended up earning
the finance minister to raise money to
cope with the consequences you talk [ __ ]
I will charge you [ __ ] say they just
social media is an internet - you know
what I mean like there's how does that
work Oh like it's African Instagram in
African Twitter what do you mean it
could just be Instagram antenna I don't
know I'm just thinking that it's they
got their own thing cuz like China got
like we all we both yeah I think it's
only China right that it has like their
own internet dude we saw a [ __ ]
dumber and all I'm trying to say China
doesn't have Google Twitter doesn't have
Instagram Korea porn is blocked on the
Internet
no not Korea porn no no no no I'm not
saying Korea important like if you go to
Korea type of pornhub you'll get a
warning you can't get into pornhub you
can't get an any like porn sites but you
could VPN into the memory you got that's
how in China that's how I like got on
you know Twitter all that use the VPN oh
my friend he's a DJ and he told me that
when he was doing his tour in Korea he
was like he really wanted a jackoff no
go to a brothel and then so yes the cab
driver and then when he went to the
brothel it was like a like an old lady
like a mamasan right and then and then
she he thought like okay cool he's gonna
she's gonna bring a girl to the room and
then she gave him a room and then she
came in and he's I off [ __ ] wait you you
work the front desk and you're the the
lady and if he said that small business
yeah he was like it was already like 3
a.m. and he was horny and he was like
[ __ ] it
welcome to the male mind okay
he said he had he got a [ __ ] from
someone that looked like his mom well
she didn't look like his mom but like
cool that's this rough dude yeah dude
David
David says that old people I'm sorry for
anyone that's all that's watching that
it takes them forever to get to live oh
yeah it doesn't I don't know man I was
like damn that's that's hardcore you
also get no teeth so yeah see that's
actually better you would be down up at
now I'm kidding it's a joke I'm kidding
you would be down what's the Kurama how
drying tip how older than you think
eighty eighty seven no I'm saying four
guys Oh for you yeah more importantly
how do they look
oh that's look ladies and women aged
pretty well until they're 70 and they
turn it to a turtle shrink right like
it's like cuz if they're 50 but they
look 30
baby yep I said 87 what if they're 80
but look 9217 look 50 play ball
oh yeah oh yeah it's just all how they
look and it's 2:00 a.m. yeah yeah
consider the other factors it's 2:00
a.m. you're horny
you can't jack off legally because they
don't have porn yeah yes you're letting
an old lady suck you off she's like one
of those odd yuma's that work at the
restaurant and it's just happening yeah
you don't have the VPN connection things
exactly will you all maybe you have your
VPN thing and then maybe I think about
it he said that he did it cuz he felt
bad and she needed to work why didn't he
just leave the tip and [ __ ] walk away
what the [ __ ] that was an excuse he's
like I just had to [ __ ] her yeah why did
he just pay her then yeah I gave her
money if he felt bad and he's like I had
it no he's tried to play the good guy
still that's amazing
good deed yeah I'm a man of my word well
I know how charging for the thing I feel
like they're already implementing
charging for Internet stuff all around
even here yeah you know I'm saying like
could I would like YouTube has its own
thing you know Spotify iTunes like
they're charging for usage everything
isn't free and
I think it's the reason like y'all
talking [ __ ] so I'm gonna put a tax on
that's probably what the outrage is
about emotion I like like he's like if
you really want to talk [ __ ] you got a
page it's a serious thing I would
definitely cough up some dota toxic [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]